cada pequeño cuadrado en la cuadrícula
es una unidad cuadrada con un área de un
centímetro cuadrado así que cada uno de
estos cuadrados es un centímetro
cuadrado aquí tenemos un centímetro
cuadrado aquí tenemos otro centímetro
cuadrado y así y nos preguntan cuál es
el área de la figura y configuran estoy
seguro que se refieren a este
cuadrilátero de color azul que tenemos
aquí y queremos saber su área y recuerda
que el área es cuánto espacio cubre una
figura
hombre eso quiere decir que vamos a
buscar cuántos centímetros cuadrados
cubren este cuadrilátero y para
averiguarlo podemos empezar a contarlos
y decir no sé se me ocurren aquí tenemos
uno de ellos este es uno y bueno podemos
decir que aquí tenemos otro y así seguir
aquí van dos aquí van tres y bueno luego
aquí en medio tenemos uno más es el 4 al
lado tenemos otro más es el 5 después
tenemos otro es el 6 y acá abajo tenemos
uno más es el 7 después sigue otro más
es el 8 y por último tenemos uno más que
es el 9 y bueno hasta aquí tenemos 9
centímetros cuadrados completos porque
tenemos 9 cuadrados completos rellenos
por aquí entonces voy a poner aquí un 9
pero ojo esta no es el área total porque
no solamente cubren estos nueve
cuadrados completos también cubren este
pedazo de aquí este triangulito de aquí
este triángulo de aquí este este y este
y por lo tanto hay que contarlos también
ahora bien por aquí puedes ver lo
siguiente si te tomas a uno de estos
triangulitos en una unidad cuadrada y lo
pones justo aquí mira este es uno de mis
triangulitos y después en la otra parte
de esta misma unidad cuadrada pones otro
de estos triangulitos lo voy a poner
justo por aquí observa que se llena por
completo una unidad cuadrada es decir
que si los combinas vas a obtener una
unidad cuadrada completa así que podemos
hacer esto y podemos tomar este
triangulito que tengo aquí déjame
tomarlo con este color
lo voy a atrapar justo así y lo voy a
combinar con este otro triangulito que
tengo aquí ya combinar estos
voy a hacer una unidad completa más
además de estas nueve es decir que al
combinar este con este estoy creando una
unidad completa más que voy a escribir
aquí así que si juntamos dos triángulos
o dos mitades de unidad cuadrada
obtenemos una más
vamos a ir haciéndolo y voy a hacer lo
mismo justo aquí tengo media unidad
cuadrada muy bien y voy a combinarlo con
este otro triangulito que está en el
mismo lado pero en la parte izquierda
así que sí junto a estos dos voy a
obtener otra unidad cuadrada más que voy
a poner justo aquí y por último tengo
estos otros dos triangulitos este de
aquí que voy a combinar con este de aquí
para crear otra nueva
y cuadrada así que la voy a poner aquí
muy bien originalmente teníamos nueve
unidades cuadradas y vamos a agregarle
otras tres unidades cuadradas más otras
tres más que hicimos juntando los
triángulos aquí hicimos la primera
unidad cuadrada extra esta que tenemos
aquí después combinamos estos dos este
con este e hicimos otra unidad cuadrada
extra y por último combinamos estos dos
e hicimos otra más otra unidad cuadrada
entonces tenemos nueve unidades
cuadradas de todos los cuadraditos
completos que teníamos más tres unidades
cuadradas o lo que es lo mismo déjame
ponerlo con este color van a ser 12
unidades cuadradas pero en este caso nos
dicen que cada unidad cuadrada cada
pequeño cuadrado es un centímetro
cuadrado así que tenemos 12 centímetros
centímetros cuadrados
y ya con esto acabamos porque podemos
decir que este cuadrilátero de aquí
cubre 12 centímetros cuadrados eso
quiere decir que este cuadrilátero tiene
un área de 12 centímetros cuadrados